So the first case of Corona virus globaly
that we know of confirmed was January 10.
The first case in the United States was January
20.
We now have well over 100000 cases heading
very quickly to 200000 cases. It's been months
since this started. And Donald Trump still
doesn't appear to know what Corona virus is,
which is, of course, a virus. Donald Trump's
almost daily Gong Show press briefings have
been truly houses of horrors. I've been covering
and lifeyou fact checking. Most of them I
took like a mental health break over the weekend,
but I did get this one moment sent to me from
the fri-, one that I have to show you, which
is Donald Trump again in the way that only
Donald Trump can, talking about something
he doesn't know about. Like no one knows about
it when in reality he's almost the only person
left who doesn't understand these basic things
about the virus.
Here is Trump saying, is this a germ? Is it
a flu? Is it a virus? No one really knows
what it is.
Pandemic by this disease.
This whatever they want to call it, you've
got a germ. You can go to a flu. You can call
it a virus. You know, you can call it many
different names. I'm not sure anybody even
knows what it is.
Is this ringing an alarm to anyone else? We're
months into this and Trump is saying things
like they don't really know what this is.
You could also, I guess, call it the Chinese
virus, which Donald Trump notably has stopped
saying clearly somebody got to him and said
that's enough with the Chinese virus stuff.
How bad is this, guys? Is it the germ flu
or virus? No one knows. It's almost April.
This has been around since January 10 with
confirmed cases. Trump was briefed on it in
December. This isn't funny anymore, as if
it ever was. It's a type of coronavirus. This
is a virus. It's not the flu. It causes respiratory
illness. It spreads through contact with infected
people when they cough or sneeze or through
contaminated surfaces. Corona virus has been
around for a long time. We've known about
them a long time. It's not the flu. The death
rate is higher. The spread ability is higher.
More people are dying daily every day that
we go. But we have an increased death toll
from this. And Trump is lecturing about they
don't even know what it is. We know you're
just not doing what needs to be done to fix
it. By and large, if Trump had said on December
30th, is it a germ flu or virus? No one knows.
You know, I'd probably say, hey, he's at least
talking about it instead of ignoring it to
say this on March. What was it? Twenty seventh
or twenty eighth when he said this whenever
it occurred over the weekend? This is truly
the stuff of horrors. And the only thing,
you know, I I am not someone who looks to
criticize Trump for everything he does when
it doesn't deserve criticism. Trump made the
right decision not to open things up on Easter.
Again, based on what he said yesterday, it
may change by tomorrow. Donald Trump said
we're extending social distancing guidelines
until April 30th. That's the right decision.
Now, had this been started earlier, we might
be looking at being able to release some of
those guidelines earlier. Doesn't the be that
as it may, this is where we are. And the right
decision today is that obviously we're not
ready to lift these guidelines in a few days.
We're going to have to go until April 30th.
That's the right decision. Trump continuing
to say things like, is this the germ? Is it
a flu? No one really knows what it is. Is
weaponized ignorance problematic to the Nth
Degree? And it's leading to Donald Trump continuing
to avoid blame and responsibility in any way
possible. As I said earlier, Donald Trump
implying or suggesting, you know, maybe the
reason we have a mask shortage isn't because
he failed, but because masks are being stolen
by hospitals. He's going to continue doing
this stuff. And in fact, we now have more
information about why we have such a shortage.
And it's not because of Obama. Let me tell
you that. And I want to address
that next.